[موسيقى]
كنت أكثر خوفًا قبل
أن أكون هناك لأنني اعتقدت ، نعم ، هذا
سيكون مجنونًا ،
ربما سأكون خائفًا حقًا
ولكن بطريقة ما عندما كنت هناك ، عندما
بدأت في التسلق
، كنت أشعر بالخوف أكثر من البحث
مثل
مشاهدة المدخنة ، أعني أنني كنت
أحترمها كثيرًا ولكن
عندما كنت في الحائط ، سقطت نوعًا ما
في التسلق لدرجة
أنني نسيت
[موسيقى] المرتفعات [موسيقى
] لا أحب
أن المدخنة  كانت لها نفس الزاوية لمسافة 360
مترًا
كما لو كانت بلاطة عمودية تقريبًا ،
لذا عندما تسقط سقطت
بقوة على الحائط في الحائط ، فهذا
شيء مختلف ،
نعم كان علي التعود على السقوط لإبقاء
هذا بعيدًا عن ذهني.  أن تكون
خائفًا من السقوط ، لذلك عليك أن تكون مركزًا
لمدة 11 ساعة
ولا يزال عليك أن تثق بشريكك
أنه بعد
ثماني ساعات من التركيز الشديد ،
سيظل شديد التركيز
بحيث لا يفسد أي تأخير أو أي شيء ،
لذا فهو يشبه  مستوى مختلف من الثقة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لقد فوجئنا حقًا بمدى صعوبة
الأمر واحتجنا إليه حقًا
عندما رأينا عدد العوامل التي يجب أن
تسير في المكان المناسب ،
كنا نوعًا ما ، نعم ، سيكون
هذا تحديًا عقليًا
للقيام بكل هذه الأشياء بشكل مثالي لك  أعرف
وكان علينا القيام بذلك بشكل مثالي
[موسيقى]
كان الأمر بمثابة إرضاء شخصي
لأنه شيء لم أفعله من قبل لم أفعله من قبل في
عدة صفحات من
قبل في
حياتي قلت أيضًا مرة واحدة أنني لا أريد ذلك
أبدًا  عد مرة أخرى
أن هذه كانت محاولتي الأخيرة
وأنني لا أريد أن أعود مرة أخرى أبدًا ، لكنها كانت
تجربة رائعة جدًا ، نعم لقد
كنت سعيدًا حقًا عندما صعدت إلى قمة
[الموسيقى]